six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller why don't we
go to the 704 area code caller from 704
Euron tell us who this is and what's on
your mind today
hey this is Gavin from Chapel Hill great
go ahead Gavin so it's a common
conservative talking point that
universities nowadays are indoctrinating
students in the following the doctrines
of socialism and communism as someone
who has experience teaching at a
university from what I know where do you
think that this notion arises well it
arises from anecdotes right and I think
this is one of those areas where there's
this movement and I don't know if I
would call it an Universalist movement
or its sort of manic an in many ways
where everything's got to be black and
white one way or the other we have to
have some principle that can be applied
100% to every situation and really most
things are shades of grey so we've done
a ton of stories about problems that
exist on some campuses with some issues
and some administration's and some
students that have been concerning but
if the argument is the mere teaching of
for example as I had at the University
of Massachusetts where I studied
economics if just having a class on
Marxist economics is an indoctrination
then we're just not going to agree and I
think I'm a good example an anecdotal
example in a way where I learned both
neoclassical and Marxist economics at
the college level and I came out with my
own ideas which is that I am NOT a
Marxist I'm not a communist but I
believe in well regulated capitalism
sort of reminiscent of the Scandinavian
model so I think that most of these just
like stereotypes and prejudices Gavan a
lot of these talking points come from
some fraction or element or grain of
something that took place in the real
world but there
blown-out work and minority yeah their
blowers I'm out sorry minority like
George this year a low Marv on Twitter
and his personal beliefs study shares
yeah I'm not sure who that is but yes I
think that that these are issues and we
want to deal with the issues but we
don't want to upend education at large
because we believe that that it's it's
become liberal indoctrination in some
kind of broad way I think that's crazy
and there's no evidence for that
agreed all right Gavin thanks very much
for the call appreciate it